with a couple inspired keyboard strokes
a brilliant idea
can come to life as a genius invention
whether it's a successful game or a
polarizing font
these four computer pioneers changed our
office life
forever
solitaire is one of the most popular
computer games of all time
and we went to find the guy who created
it
yes may i help you are you the person
that wrote solitaire for microsoft
yes but that was a long time ago we
gotta talk can we come in
great thank you all right
this is wes i'm wes cherry and i wrote
windows solitaire
i wrote the game in 1988 as an intern
uh internships at microsoft were really
all encompassing things but i squeezed
it in there in a few little hours
of my free time for those who need a
refresher solitaire was played on the
computer using a mouse
cards are pulled from the deck in an
effort to stack cards in order by suit
and if you won you got an awesome
display of cards
cascading towards you i came up with the
idea to write solitaire for windows
out of boredom really there wasn't many
games right at the time
so we had to make them in the mid to
late 90s was just when people started
really getting computers in their home
microsoft officially said that solitaire
was there to
teach people how to use the mouse but in
reality it was just really just
something to have fun with before there
were released windows of course bill
gates
got a shot at it his biggest complaint
was that solitaire was too hard to win
and once people figured out the mouse it
became a favorite pastime
the number of hours wasted on solitaire
is really countless
i can say that right after solitaire was
released
in 1990 there was a world recession so
many people were playing it in the
workplace that wes came up with what he
called the boss
key pressed a special key and a
spreadsheet would come up
it made it look like you were doing real
work but microsoft made me take it out
considering this game has been around
for decades you must have made a ton of
money
i was not paid not a single cent at one
time i said if i
only got a penny for copy i would be
very rich
so far only 14 people have made good on
that i'm still waiting for the rest of
you
well you heard the man do you still work
with computers i work with
apple now apples actually and i own a
cidery
uh wes there's something behind you
let's run
it's a time-honored thing to put your
name on your artistic productions
writers have their name on the book
painters write their name in the corner
why couldn't video game designers have
their name and their games
this is a story about one man who took
on a giant tech company and changed the
gaming world in the process
[Music]
my name is warren robinette i'm the
creator of adventure
the first action adventure game this was
a video game
that i wrote working for atari in the
late 70s
they treated us badly in several
different ways
no royalties no name on the box no
external recognition
being told that we were easily
replaceable they disrespected us
so warren hatch the perfect plan what i
did was i hid
my name in the game in a secret room
that was really hard to get to
when you got in there the screen filled
up with
a flashing movie marquee that said
created by warren robinette
atari shipped out 200 000 copies of
adventure before anyone discovered
warren's secret room
how did they find out about that a 15
year old boy in salt lake city
wrote a letter to atari and he very
clearly
explained how to get into the secret
room and warren
wasn't worried at all about
repercussions what are they going to do
take away my royalty well they weren't
giving us any royalties
fire me so happened that i'd already
quit but to warren's surprise his active
rebellion was well received by atari's
new lead game designer steve wright
he's musing to himself about this
situation and he said
it was kind of cool to have hidden
surprises in video games
it's like waking up on easter morning
and going out and finding
colored easter eggs under the bushes and
flowers
everything ended alright for warren
robinette you can't say the same for
atari
atari actually collapsed in one year it
imploded
personally i think there's some poetic
justice there that the big
powerful rich new york pushy guys
could not defeat the one little 26 year
old programmer who just had a sneaky
idea
and pulled it off without telling
anybody
it's 1995. your word processor is open
and before you press a single key you
make the most important decision of your
life
what font do i use all the usual fonts
are too
conventional there were very few very
casual typefaces
that you could use you keep scrolling
too stately too boring but then
it pops out of the menu what is this
font
it was so different than everything else
the way it flows is
strange it had irregularity about it
and uniquely flawed the stems aren't
perfectly straight they're
quite wobbly this is the font you want
and in that moment you and millions of
other people click on the button that
says
comic sans how did a font both loathe
and cherish come to dominate the world
my name is vincent kanair i was a
typographic engineer at microsoft
i contributed to lots of fonts like
webbings trebuchet
and most notably comic sans so it's all
my fault
to understand comic sans you have to
understand its creator years before his
work at microsoft
vincent was working on his undergrad in
new york city we went to university in
the 1980s
i was a quite young rebellious fine arts
student
he'd spend a lot of time in art spaces
and i'd walk through the galleries of
the old soho and
look at paintings and artwork to him
what separated good art from bad art was
this simple benchmark
if you didn't notice them i consider
that was bad
and if you did notice it was good
because at least they made you stop and
look
it either shocked you or you really
liked it but if you didn't even notice
and you just walked through
it was a disaster vincent would take
that philosophy to microsoft where he
was challenged to make a playful font
for a program called microsoft bob
and so i looked at batman and
the watchmen and pretty much tried to
draw on the computer something that
looked similar to that but not
copying it so that's how comic sans was
made by
just looking at comic books and comic
characters
not everyone was a fan of the fonts
quirks my boss robert norton he didn't
really like the font
and he thought it should be a bit more
typographic
and i argued and said no it should be
weird and i thought it stood out and it
wasn't
boring typography that's in a school
book
though the font didn't make it to the
release of microsoft bob it was
eventually pre-installed on every
macintosh by 1996.
i started to see it when it was in in
the wild so to speak
the first one i remember was a neon sign
over a store called fun stamps that's
when i realized it's going to get used
any way anybody wants to use it and that
just
snowballed from there the font spread
like wildfire
in ways vincent didn't even imagine when
i travel the world and see it in
on beach towels war memorials on bread
street signs on everything its
overexposure even spurred a group of
designers to start an anti-comic sans
movement
i thought it was funny i didn't really
find it offensive
after all these years vincent finds
himself content with how history will
remember him
and comic sans is not one of the better
pieces of art but conceptually it's one
of the best things i've ever done
it probably is the best thing i have
ever done
[Music]
this is the ibm personal computer it was
the most advanced computing machine
ever created however this isn't a story
about a computer
but a story about when a computer stops
working and the man who created a way to
start it all over
the man who invented control alt delete
let's get into it hi i'm dr dave bradley
but you can call me dr dave back in 1980
i worked on the ibm
personal computer my particular job on
the ibm pc was writing the basic input
output system
even with an elite team of engineers and
designers not everything goes smoothly
when you're building a computer
we had programs that ran most of the
time but when they failed
the only way to reset the system was
turn the power off
wait a while turn the power back on and
it would go through a very long
self-test
but the system might die every five to
ten minutes
what he needed was a way to shortcut the
restart process
[Music]
one of the things we discussed was
putting a reset button
on it but if you put it on the system
board there's a chance that you could
hit it by mistake
and all your data gets lost
so what we did was came up with a three
key sequence
that would reset the computer and you
couldn't hit by mistake
a single control key a single alt key
and then all the way over at the right
hand side a single delete key
when you hit that control alt delete
you're deleting everything that you're
working on right now and starting new
i was also able to skip over many of the
tests
so instead of taking a minute or two it
was 10 or 15 seconds
but it wasn't a big deal at the time it
was like
number 17 on the list of 100 different
things i had to fix
even though it was built only as a
development tool programmers began
incorporating the feature into their
applications
from there it was released into the wild
but didn't immediately reach pop culture
status
for years it was no big deal and then at
the 20th anniversary of the ibm pc
that's when control ultimately became
sort of a cultural life
it was the simplest and easiest way to
fix your problem
hit control all delete start all over
despite all this dr dave doesn't think
much of this contribution to computing
history
i did lots of things with ibm but all
everybody remembers is control all
delete
but i'll take that the fame of
control-alt-delete
means that i worked on a very successful
product
and i'm very proud of having been able
to do that
[Music]
hey everybody my name is drew beebe and
i'm here in my terrible
home studio that i've made during
quarantine
and i wanted to tell you about our new
podcast called great big story
it's got more surprising and delightful
stories just like this one
so head over to apple podcast to spotify
wherever you get your favorite podcasts
and download
great big story